le gars sur scène nous dit qu'il est
bien de l'afrique mais les blancs
comment ça se fait et bien que je skie
plan parce que mon père est français
ma mère y je suis né en egypte j'ai
conduit en afrique du sud
et c'est tout une afrique du sud qu'il
aime par dessus tout et les bouvron on
dresse un portrait intime et drôle où
est ce que on trouve nos racines
c'est là où on a grandi je pense je
pense comment l'enfant en ressent les
choses tellement forte
ça nous marque et donc on a toujours
besoin de retourner à ce cocon avec
africa eric bouvron accompagné de son
acolyte matos invite le public à
découvrir l'autre les autres une ode à
la générosité
[Musique]
cette maman ma mère qui m'a appris ça le
côté grec aussi de accueillir et de de
données j'aspire raid généreux on dit
souvent comédiens soient généreux la
générosité cdh est vulnérable et être
près de rater aussi un spectacle qui
unit pour faire rire
eric bouvron est aussi le directeur
artistique du rire soleil un festival
fait de représentation et d'ateliers au
sein des écoles avec un mot clé le rire
l'humour et fédérateur déjà ça réunit
les gens se la met ensemble et s'auto je
suis pas fan des rares les temps sont
durs il faut il faut qu on convient j'ai
envie que les gens partagent un moment
de bien quelque part un festival qui
prendra fin le 30 mars prochain cette
fois c'est arnaud cosson philibeaux est
un espace qui auront la mission de vous
faire rire
[Applaudissements]